even before it can be seen a sure sign
of autumn echoes across the high country
it's just such a haunting beautiful
incredible sound with Dawn's approach
figures emerge in the growing light
engaged in a timeless ritual the balls
are bugling to claim their territory and
to keep other Bulls from challenging
their dominance over a harem this time
of year life renews itself in Rocky
Mountain National Parks elk herd this is
their mating season all weekends are now
one of the busiest times at Rocky
Mountain National Park so busy that
Rangers spend most of their time dealing
with people instead of Wildlife
some of the problems that we have to
deal with are people trying to get too
close to the elk despite a
picture-perfect setting
getting the shot here requires as much
patience as film I'd love to be out here
without a bunch of people but you know
it's it's so neat everybody wants to
come and everyone wants to come and
experience it peaceful elk viewing
experience is usually just a short hike
away and worth the effort during mating
season bull elk constantly prepare for
battle confrontations that occasionally
prove fatal during this time period the
Bulls will challenge each other for the
cows and this particular Bowl challenged
and apparently he lost losing usually
means little more than being chased off
by a larger Pole okay now let Logan hit
see this young one with the small rack
he's kind of moving in he's gonna try
he's coming down from behind him up
there so what's gonna happen with him
well he's just he's just soreness yeah
he's just hurting his cows together
they're separated from these other guys
he's gonna try to in the fading light
there is the hope of being thrilled by
the call of the wild one last time
it's a pretty good spot you can tell
them the hoofprints and the dirt they
come by here regularly with darkness
closing in the people are finally gone
and at least for now the elk have the
Park to themselves their songs carried
across the Twilight heard only by the
mountains